اذا اسبوعان حاسما يفصلان اردوغان
وكليتشدار اوغلو عن جوله ختاميه تقرر من
سيحكم تركيا للفتره المقبله في جوله
انتخابات رئاسيه ثانيه تعد الاولى في
تاريخ تركيا التي تتزامن طبعا ويتزامن
اجراؤها مع الذكرى المئه لتاسيس البلاد
كجمهوريه عقب انهيار الامبراطوريه
العثمانيه نسبه المشاركه مشاهدينا كانت
قياسيه وغير مسبوقه وصلت الى
89% ولكن ما الذي سيفعله اردوغان خلال
هذين الاسبوعين لاقناع الناخبين بضروره
استمراره رئيسا للبلاد اولا يواجه الرجل
اي اردوغان صعوبات وتحديات لجذب كتله
ناخبه جديده تحسم المنافسه لصالحه لان
اولويه ان ناخذ التركيه اليوم هي مواجهه
الصعوبات الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه التي فشلت
فيها سياسات الغير معهوده اقتصاديا وهنا
يراهن اردوغان على شعبيته بين الناخبين
الريفيين والطبقه العامله والمتدينين
الذين ينسبون اليه الفضل بتطوير البلاد
وتعزيز مكانتها الدوليه خلال العشرين سنه
الماضيه ايضا سيعمل اردوغان على استقطاب
اصوات مناصري المرشح الثالث وهو سنان
اوغان الحاصل بحسب النتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات على 5% من الاصوات بحسب طبعا
النتائج الرسميه حيث من المرجح ان يفضله
اتباع اوجان القوميين اليمينيين تقول هنا
صحيفه نيويورك تايتس هذا كان عن اردوغان
ولكن ماذا عن اوغلو اوغلو هو مرشح
المعارضه سيستغل نقاط ضعف خصمه اردوغان
لكسب اصوات مناصريه والمترددين ايضا كما
سيعمل زعيم المعارضه لتعزيز خطابه الانتخ
والاجتماعي والاقتصادي الذي نجح فيه الى
حد كبير بنيل فقط الاتراك بطبيعه الحال
كالجدار اوغلو لن ينسى ورقته الرابحه
والتي عززت طبعا حضوره وصوتت لصالحه خلال
مختلف المحطات الانتخابيه واعطته هذه
المره 20% من الاصوات الناخبه هذه الورقه
هي الاكراد طبعا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات